carrie is in
dallas texas hi carrie happy new year
hey hey dave happy new year to you too
and thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um okay so
um your problem child i have
lots of credit card debt um
to the tune of 70 thousand dollars
in credit card debt and yeah
and i um you know purchased
my first home um four years ago almost
and um lots of things went wrong um
uh with it but that wasn't all
the debt and i was given advice
from a friend a year ago
to just stop paying the credit card debt
they were all zero percent and
all the interest rates started i knew
they were about to skyrocket
and it was going to get to the point
when i couldn't even make minimum
payments anymore
and so they just said quit paying just
stop paying and i did try to call
several of them
and they weren't willing to negotiate
anything with me they
they didn't want to talk to me because i
was current on everything yeah
and i had always been of course
so now they're all coming full circle
all right i'll tell you what hold on we
come back from this break we'll get the
rest of your story and see if we can
help you we're talking with carrie in
dallas texas she ran up 70 000
in credit card debt as the interest
rates went from zero
to full blown as they always do she was
unable to make the payments her friends
suggested she stop
and that's about how far we got in the
conversation what else is going on miss
carrie
yes sir well i started working your
program last month
i reached out and a financial advisor
found me and we've already met she's got
me on a budget
um she i've done plastic surgery
i've done all her homework we're meeting
friday again for the new update things
are actually going great i was going to
say you actually while you're out of
control you're starting to feel in
control
i'm more in control i mean it's the
first time i've ever been on a budget
before
um i i checked out every dollar but i
think with all this default debt i felt
that you need a budget or y in ab.com
uh was better for me i don't because of
all this
unknown i don't know i don't know um you
need to get on every dollar
okay yeah it's going to be much better
you just need to run two debt snowballs
as well
okay so i've got all my default debt um
i settled or i just settled and paid two
of them
i knocked two of the cards off myself i
got summons
for two others through the same
collection agency
or law firm and i did get a lawyer for
the first one
and could kick myself because i realized
i could do it myself
um so we he settled for me
on the first one and then i guess it
gave me the template to know how to do
it
um so that's what i paid for but i
settled the second one
my question is um on the debt snowball
with those
they're gonna be coming at me you know
the different amounts
are coming at me and once it goes i get
a summons i've got to settle those out
no you don't so i don't okay
um they can show you they can show you
but in texas they really can't do
anything
well i thought they could get control of
my bank account which would be
not in texas um not in texas i thought
i they can't can't garnish your wages
well you don't need that you don't need
to give them your bank account
information
right well i figured i could just switch
bank accounts if that were the case yeah
okay yeah so okay we're not gonna let
their we're not gonna let them create
the emergency we're gonna let you create
it
so all of these this entire 70 000 is in
default
yes sir okay and what other debts do you
have
i only have my um my home
loan which i owe 178
on that are you current car i am current
i'm current on everything else
the car 707 000. perfect
my income is 78 000.
okay and i'm also working i've been
doing ubereats
on the side delivering um and i was able
to pull in five hundred dollars last
week
so way to go um i'm planning to just
keep
attacking that as well you're inspiring
i mean you're inspiring you made a huge
mess and then when you decide to do
something about it
you got a template from the lawyer you
met with a financial advisor you're
working your plan you picked up an extra
job
you made a budget you're doing
everything you are really on fire i'm so
proud of you for what i do
so i am and i just want to keep this
fire and
take care so as you got as you get
little summons
if you want to stop and settle those
that's fine but if you get
one that's a huge one just let it sit
there's one coming up it's
like 8 000 you know 8 200. and i told
them
i spoke with them on the phone and she
wasn't willing to talk to me
without she wanted me to make a good
faith painter so we're not doing that
today
um i just need to know what you would be
willing to settle for so i can
you know plan for that and be able to
give that to you in a month or two
and she goes i can't do anything with
you right now
you know then hang up and so i
said go ahead and slam the phone down
just for the satisfaction
just for the satisfaction the woman is
she's going to act like she's a test
pilot for a broom factory treat her that
way
okay that was her decision not yours
it's not you know that's all a technique
that's called intimidation
and don't don't let them do that to you
you got a plan you're on fire you got a
system
and so what you're gonna do let me
here's what's gonna happen okay you have
three different
uh summons and or collectors coming at
you
and you have two thousand dollars
sitting there this is in the future
this is in the future what you're gonna
just you're gonna mess with every one of
them you're gonna go
i got 2 thousand dollars who wants it
first
if you take it you will get that as a
settlement on eight thousand dollars
that's behind door number one
if you don't then we're gonna go to door
number two and whichever one of you
calls me back first
that's who's getting this money i'll get
back to the rest of you later when i got
some money
and this is a game show baby you know
and just have some fun with it right and
then you know how to settle it you've
got the template to do that get it in
writing and do not allow them electronic
access to your checking account
that way they don't know where the flip
it is
right and they don't clean you out on
the rest of your plan
but i did settle on this law firm i did
the two
that i settled on i do not need to pay
online or anything like that or
because it is in a settlement am i safe
to just go online and pay them
or do i need to do the cashier's check
every time
online means they have your bank account
information
yeah i would think they would do not do
that don't do it okay no
okay that's what i thought i just wanted
to add because they they
it once they have that if they're
unscrupulous and
some of them are they can turn around
and clean out your bank account
okay so you're to get around to working
with everybody we're not trying to
ditch them we're not trying to be a
deadbeat we're just not going to be
abused and we're going to play them
against each other until we get through
this
so i need to start with my default debt
snowball
smallest to largest on that i do have
three cards that are current
um i'd knock them out if you can't get a
smaller amount i'd knock them out
first yeah go ahead and knock them out
you know
again i thought that my advisor was
saying it's telling me different
well normally normally what we tell you
what your advisor was trained to do and
normally what we tell you is
run two debt snowballs run your current
stuff and pay it off first and let all
the stuff that's in default just sit
and once you've gotten rid of the car
payment and the three active credit
cards everything but your house
then that gives you more cash flow to
deal with the stuff that's in default
that's our normal routine
you've got a few of them coming at you
right now and so if you want to uh
kind of dodge around a little bit head
fake and jump in and out of that
and jump over and knock out one of those
summons that's okay there's not a bad
thing here okay what i don't want you to
do is i don't want
them threatening you or giving you a
hard time or
bossing you around to become the
priority instead
you set your priorities you have power
over money for the first time in your
life carrie
use it right you make me don't worry
about them taking me to court then
because sometimes that's you feel
pressure to settle nope before
court we can settle after just as good
not worried about
but i thought that they would do the
full amount plus court costs
well they will but we're also going to
negotiate that down to 10 cents on the
dollar
okay and they're gonna be happy to get
it junk debt it is junk
these aren't junk debt it is junk debt
it's a credit card that's in default
it's called junk debt
okay that's what it is because they all
say they're representing the card
itself it's still well i don't give a
crap third party
they either own it or they don't but
when they get ready to sell it they're
going to sell it for a nickel on the
dollar
right and so that's what it's worth to
them it's
junk debt it's it's it's almost a year
since they've been paid
they have their probabilities they know
their probability is almost zero it's
five percent
chance they're going to get paid and the
fact that you're working with them gets
them all excited you actually have a
phone number that works
everybody else in their database doesn't
i mean that's
who they're dealing with and so you're
you're like a unicorn for them they're
so happy to talk to somebody to abuse
you
so karen is great craig carrie you're
doing great listen if you're not in
ramsey plus i'm gonna put you in it hold
on
kelly pick up and make sure you're tied
into that because you were doing
everything right to straighten out your
life you are doing a full reset